L'épidémie d'opiacés n'a fait qu'amplifier ce fardeau.
Quand j'ai été embauchée par la bibliothèque publique en 2013,
j'ai spécifiquement choisi de travailler à McPherson
car je comprends ce que c'est de grandir dans un environnement
où les troubles liés à l'usage de drogues façonnent le quotidien
et je voulais utiliser ces expériences personnelles
comme guide pour mon travail.
Avant d'en venir à cela,
je veux partager ce que c'était
de voir cette épidémie croître à Kensington.
Comme beaucoup d'autres communautés, nous n'étions pas prêts.
Nous avons commencé à remarquer les pièces d'identité :
des adresses de comtés voisins et du nord
puis, peu à peu, d'en dehors de l'État.
Des gens d'Arkansas, d'Ohio, de Caroline du sud, d'Alabama
venant à Philadelphie pour de l'héroïne bon marché.
Les gens s'attardaient de plus en plus longtemps dans nos toilettes publiques,
ce qui nous a fait prêter plus attention aux toilettes
qu'à nos responsabilités quotidiennes
car c'était un endroit accessible
où consommer des drogues tout juste achetées.
Un jour, nos toilettes étaient tellement bouchées
que nous avons dû fermer notre bibliothèque pendant deux jours
car les responsables de l'obstruction étaient des aiguilles usagées.
Depuis un certain temps avant cet incident,
nous demandions une poubelle pour les objets tranchants
et, après cela,
l'administration de la bibliothèque a vite approuvé son installation
ainsi que l'embauche de personnel surveillant les toilettes.
Les températures augmentant,
nous avons eu du mal à répondre.
Les gens campaient dans le parc des jours, des semaines durant.
Vous pouviez vous promener un jour beau et chaud
et trouver de multiples groupes de gens dans divers états d'intoxication
avec des enfants jouant au milieu.
Le nombre d'aiguilles ramassées par Teddy par mois est monté en flèche,
passant de 100 à 300, à 500, à 800,
à plus de 1 000,
dont beaucoup trouvées sur nos marches et sur le terrain de jeux.
Puis il y a eu les overdoses.
Tant d'entre elles ont eu lieu dehors dans le parc,
certaines dans la bibliothèque.
Sterling, notre gardien, passait son temps
à parcourir l'intérieur et l'extérieur du bâtiment
ainsi que le parc,
s'assurant constamment que tout le monde allait bien
car, certaines fois,
notre peur d'avoir quelqu'un faisant une overdose et mourant
a failli se réaliser.
Une overdose en particulier s'est produite après l'école,
la bibliothèque était pleine d'enfants, de bruit et d'agitation.
Au milieu de tout cela,
nous avons entendu un bruit sourd venant des toilettes.
En ouvrant la porte, nous avons trouvé un homme au sol, inconscient.
Il a été sorti devant tout le monde --
enfants, ados, adultes, familles.
Un employé a appelé les urgences,
quelqu'un d'autre a conduit les enfants et ados en bas,
quelqu'un est allé faire signe à l'ambulance dans le parc.
Nous autres,
nous avons juste attendu.
C'était devenu habituel en cas d'overdose
car à l'époque, c'était tout ce que nous pouvions faire.
Nous avons attendu et regardé cet homme s'étouffer --
convulser.
Il était en train de mourir.
Je ne sais pas si certains d'entre vous ont été témoin d'une overdose d'opiacés
mais c'est terrible
car vous savez que la difficulté à respirer,
la perte de couleur du visage de quelqu'un
sont un minuteur faisant s'écouler les chances de survie de cette personne.
Heureusement pour cet homme,
l'ambulance est arrivée
et il a reçu une dose de naxolone par injection.
Je me souviens qu'il a tressauté comme s'il avait été électrocuté,
il a retiré l'aiguille
et il a dit aux ambulanciers de reculer.
Puis il s'est levé et il est parti.
Et nous --
nous nous sommes remis au travail
car les gens demandaient toujours du temps sur les ordinateurs,
les enfants de l'aide avec leurs devoirs
et c'était notre travail --
notre mission.
Je pense que cet incident m'est resté du fait de l'attente.
Je me suis sentie impuissante.
C'est ce sentiment d'impuissance qui m'a tant rappelé mon enfance.
Avant ma naissance, mes deux parents ont commencé à prendre de l'héroïne.
Cela a rendu nos vies chaotiques et instables :
des promesses faites et jamais tenues,
leurs disputes, le poids du secret --
le poids de notre secret a maintenu le « normal » en dehors de nos vies.
Chaque fois que nous étions déposés chez nos grands-parents,
je restais bloquée sur l'idée que je ne les reverrai plus jamais.
Chaque fois que nous étions laissés dans une voiture, une maison, un magasin,
je pleurais.
Dès que je voyais les lignes ferroviaires aériennes --
celles que je prends maintenant pour aller travailler à McPherson --
depuis l'arrière de la voiture,
je me mettais en colère
car même les enfants savent
quand leurs parents essayent d'acheter de la drogue.
Je pouvais faire si peu pour contrôler ce qu'il se passait autour de moi
que ce sentiment d'impuissance était accablant.
J'avais des difficultés à l'école, j'avais du mal à lire,
j'étais encline à la colère, à la dépression.
J'ai commencé à fumer à 11 ans,
ce qui m'a vite menée à mes propres expériences avec les drogues et l'alcool.
Je me suis convaincue que le passé de mes parents serait mon avenir.
Mais finalement, mes deux parents se sont désintoxiqués
et sont restés sobres.
Leur force et leur engagement
nous a offert, à mes frères et sœurs et moi, du soutien et de la stabilité
et ce sont ces expériences personnelles qui m'ont menée à McPherson.
En choisissant d'être bibliothécaire
et d'être à McPherson,
j'ai renoncé à mon sentiment d'impuissance
et j'ai trouvé des façons d'aider les autres.
Une façon d'apporter mon aide
était d'apprendre à administrer du naxolone.
Les bibliothèque publiques répondent aux besoins de leurs communautés
et ne pas savoir comment utiliser du naxolone
ne servait pas les besoins de notre communauté.
Nous étions en première ligne
et avions désespéramment besoin d'avoir accès à ces outils vitaux.
Finalement, fin février 2017,
après l'avoir beaucoup réclamé,
nous avons reçu une formation de Prevention Point Philapdelphia
et environ un mois plus tard,
j'ai utilisé du naxolone pour la première fois pour sauver une vie.
C'était après l'école.
Teddy est entré pour nous dire que quelqu'un faisait une overdose dehors.
Un employé a appelé les urgences
et j'ai attrapé le kit de naxolone.
La femme avait à peine 20 ans et respirait à peine.
Son amie la giflait frénétiquement
en espérant la réveiller.
J'ai administré le naxolone par le nez
et, heureusement, elle est revenue à elle.
Mais avant que l'ambulance n'arrive,
elle et son amie se sont enfuies.
Quand je me suis retournée,
j'ai vu les enfants --
les enfants venant à la bibliothèque tous les jours,
certains que je connais depuis des années --
se tenant sur les marches du bâtiment.
Ils ont tout vu.
Ils ne semblaient pas être bouleversés ou en état de choc
alors je suis entrée dans le bâtiment,
dans notre salle de travail, et j'ai pleuré.
En partie à cause du choc de ce qu'il s'était passé
car je n'avais jamais pensé que je sauverais une vie,
mais surtout pour les enfants.
C'est leur normalité.
C'est la normalité de la communauté.
C'est une normalité catastrophique
et, à ce moment-là,
j'ai été confrontée de force au fait que cela ne devrait jamais être normal
et, comme dans mon enfance,
quand vous le vivez, vous l'acceptez.
L'épidémie d'opiacés ne touche pas que ceux vivant
avec un trouble lié à leur usage
car la portée de l'épidémie va bien au-delà de ceux vivant avec
et de leurs familles.
Elle affecte toute la communauté.
Kensington était une communauté en crise avant cela
pour des raisons qui sont endémiques et entrelacées
et qui connaît le quartier sait pourquoi :
les inégalités raciales,
l'incapacité du gouvernement local et fédéral de financer les écoles,
le manque d'opportunités économiques.
Et ce que nous essayons de faire à McPherson,
c'est de trouver des façons d'aider la communauté à sortir de la crise.
Peut-être que du fait de cette épidémie,
plus de gens prêtent attention à Kensington.
Mais indépendamment de cela,
à McPherson,
nous continuerons à faire ce que nous pouvons
avec les ressources que nous avons
et à apporter toute l'aide que nous pouvons
dans l'espoir de garder notre communauté saine et sauve
car les bibliothèques publiques ont toujours été plus que des livres.
Nous sommes un abri physique,
une salle de classe,
un refuge,
une salle à manger,
un centre de ressources
et, oui,
même une bouée de sauvetage.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)